[Music]
are your kids now off to college you've
sort of lost your identity a bit
direction or focus well there's help
help from one of the top las vegas
makeup artists for celebrities and
politicians who has now expanded her
focus to help women reestablish
themselves off the horse
then you have your pity party and then
it's time to get up and get back on the
horse
and very slowly barbara joe batterman of
the batterman group created a full
service agency representing some of the
most talented makeup hair and wardrobe
stylist to the stars she's lived here in
vegas since the 90s
hired for the billboard music awards
acma's miss america pageants
she's worked on paul mccartney president
barack obama heidi klum toby keith in
addition to thousands of others
and during the pandemic she got
certified as a reset coach for women
especially the women that have had a
family and
raised their kids and now their kids are
off to university
and they're feeling well now what am i
supposed to do and
it's their time so i'm all about putting
them up on a little pedestal and
having them rise a little bit and say
okay what do i want to do and how do i
want to feel and what do i have to do
to help myself a reset coach takes
things
one step at a time the council is free
if you're interested after that barbara
joe asks for a three-month commitment
because
she says it takes that amount of time to
see any noticeable change
you can contact her through her website
at thebattermangroup.com and she is
fabulous she's helped
make us look stunning for our new year's
eve production as well so we thank her
for what she's done to make us good
there as well